hello everyone we're pleased to have you
join us for cardinal health lab exchange
welcome to today's live broadcast iqcp
let's get it started I'm Brenda Kelly
Kim of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's webinar we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab groups and
sponsored by alir alir delivers reliable
and actionable information for rapid
diagnostic tests resulting in better
clinical and economic health care
outcomes globally for more information
please visit www CN HTML I'd like to
announce to our audience that in a few
moments some polls will appear on your
screen if you could take a second to
answer those polls we'd love to have the
results that we can discuss during this
presentation before we begin though we
have of just a few announcements the
webcast we're having today is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them into
the green Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems hearing or seeing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left following this presentation
please head on over to the community of
learning in the lab exchange lobby where
you'll have the opportunity to engage in
my attack and have more of your
questions answered promise talk about IQ
pc i would now like to introduce today's
speaker Jane Smith Jane received her BA
and medical technology in the University
of Tennessee
natsu received her master's degrees in
science education and environmental
engineering she worked with an
immunology supervisor for 30 years at
the University of Tennessee Knoxville
before joining the alere Clinical
Immunology group in 2011 she was one of
the founding members of a leer
scientific affairs where she now serves
as a technical manager Jane has been
active in volunteering nationwide for
calf inspections she is also volunteered
in cos I poct for a three point of care
ivd testing and qms 03 training and
competence assessment documents Jane is
currently directing the cross functional
iqcp team to provide iqcp support
materials 40 near products or now turn
it over to Jane or her presentation
hello everyone and thanks Brenda for the
nice introduction as I'm speaking here
we're going to be finishing up the polls
and I look over that after i do my
introduction first of all i'm delighted
to talk to you about the big change in
performing quality control i know a lot
of people out there anxious about this
but this is an opportunity for iqcp to
be a more inclusive approach to assuring
quality IQ CPS will provide laboratories
with more flexibility and the tests
quality control will fit their specific
test in their laboratories iqcp is also
going to provide an opportunity as
technology advances and iqcp is more
flexible for test of the future and I
think we've done in our last poll here
we got one more to submit here and we'll
take a look at the results yes and I'll
XML here oh and I'm glad to see that I'm
going to do the last one first because I
see it I'm really excited to see that
looking for pen to paper suggestions as
a medical technologist I really during
this presentation I'm going to help
guide you through some things that I
think the inspectors are going to be
looking for an easy ways to organize
this I noticed that the percentage I was
like seven nine percent that people had
not started on their iqcp and guess what
that's not that much different than what
we've seen in the field doing this
presentation and most of you guys are
listening to these webinars and they're
getting great information so I just
wanted to let you know that hopefully
this presentation will be a little more
practical for you for getting started on
your iqcp and lift the last poll we're
going to close it out
and this is the agenda today first we're
going to talk about how we got here and
this will be a brief history very brief
the next thing that we're going to talk
about is we're going to review the
elements of an iqcp risk assessment and
believe me this was the new portion for
me I never done risk assessment till I
started working on this project for a
year and I believe in the laboratory
this will be new that's why we're going
to spend most of our time on the risk
management concepts we will also briefed
a review on the quality control portion
of annika iqcp and the quality
assessment on the third thing the item
as a volunteer CIP inspector I hope to
give you as you requested tend to pay
for suggestions for your inspection for
preparing for an iqcp and then next
we're going to show you somewhere I qcp
support documents and the reason we're
going to be using these is because I'm
really more familiar with the Lear
products there are many other
manufacturers out there that are
providing iqcp support documents that
you can use you can even use ours even
if you don't you don't use our products
I think you can get some good ideas from
them the principle is the same you'll be
able to translate from the Lear products
into many of your other products and
finally at the end of the presentation
we should have plenty of time for
questions from each one of you and how
did we get here and this is the brief
I'm history timeline but i'm really
going to skip ahead here what i want to
do is skip to the quality on system
regulations this is when they define how
they wanted quality control done and
then the next thing that followed very
shortly you notice was within one year
we came up with quality control
equivalent quality control
and the CFO CFR regulation for 93.1 256
for each test system you know if you
need to do run controls extra logic
controls two levels or three depending
on the specialty that a non weight has
dis perform please keep in mind this is
for non wave testing but shortly after
CMS came out with an a way to reduce the
number of controls which was called
equivalent quality control people in
point of care have been really familiar
with how to do equivalent quality
control but I am going to go over it
briefly so people can understand the
history of why we managed to do a new
type of quality control this is from the
CLIA brochure number four which you can
get online from CMS and for doing an
evaluation for an option one this is one
that monitors all the analytic
components of the a test system and it's
recommended that you would take your
internal monitoring systems compare it
for 10 days to your external QC and
after that after medical or your
laboratory director approves you'll have
at least once per month you would only
have to run your external controls the
second option that they provided was if
it monitored only a portion of the
process this one was a bit longer a
30-day consecutive study comparing
external controls again this one is a
little bit different at least once per
week CIP offers something very similar
if your inspected by them they do what's
called a 20-day consecutive study so
just to keep those processes straight as
far as option three I have never seen it
used in a laboratory but it is
definitely in the playa brochure okay
back to the history here one thing about
equal
quality control a lot of people in the
scientific community felt that the
option one of only doing ten results was
really not valid so this is what brought
us to quality control of the future and
we had experts from across the united
states that had a meeting and this
included industry laboratories of
different types and it was decided that
we really needed to look at quality
control in based using risk management
concepts so very luckily um sillas i
developed a document that was to be used
it will be used as a reference and
that's when it was completed in 2011
this was done by dr. jim nichols and
actually somebody from scientific
affairs earlier it was actually on the
committee too and they were really good
because they gave a reference actually
for the eventual letter that came out
from Judy Yost in 2013 that did occur
intended got for doing an individual
quality control plan and keep in mind
the clsi document is you do not have to
use the format that's in it it's just a
very good reference I think that tools
of risk management are like learning a
new language and and it's very nice to
have this for reference if you're if
you're not comfortable with using risk
management skills currently you can use
two to three levels of QC and you can
continue on if you want examples of
people that are labs that would maybe
not want to change is perhaps you only
did a test once or twice a month it
might be worth just keeping on and just
doing controls external controls when
you run the test equivalent quality
control is okay
right now to use it but as of january
first 2016 you'll no longer be able to
use it and the other portion of it is
you cannot grandfather your test in if
you've done eqc in the past you will
have to convert those two iqcp iqcp is
um you can use it now but CMS and have
started inspecting and looking for it
just the starts of it other credit
agencies such as joint commission and
cap are just recently getting their
standards and checklist questions out
there so people will begin once I see
those begin to work on there will be
they'll be working on their IQ cps
including that and i wanted to you know
mention that i think they're already out
i'm not sure where the updates are those
you might want to check if you're
inspected by joint commission or cap so
what are the elements of an iqcp you've
got the risk assessment you have a
quality control plan and quality
assessment the risk assessment is new
for most people in the lab again this is
why we need to spend most of our time
today learning how to use risk
management tools remember that risk
analysis is identifying all the
pre-analytical post analytical and live
pre-analytical analytical post
analytical on steps and then you need to
divide these and types of failures which
will go into more detail later you're
already doing quality control but keep
in mind there's a lot more to quality
control than just liquid QC it's also
the things that you are always doing in
laboratory anyhow you're reading
refrigerator temperatures your training
on new procedures and combin sees you do
your task verification when you set up
new testing quality control is a list of
procedures in place to help manage the
risk found in your own risk assessment
true QC will prevent or
or detect risk QA is just another way to
monitor or track your IQ CB plan again
you'll use your existing plan and more
likely at your QA after you've
identified new failures from looking
things through a risk assessment nope
you're going to note appropriate
corrective action and evaluate if
changes need to be made to on your
quality control plan and the iqcp will
include documentation of these changes
things to consider for risk management
if the probability of how bad it can get
and and and how often this is going to
happen is what you're really going to be
looking at for risk management
understand that a hazard is something
that can go wrong and the risk is just
the probability the severity of harm
that it can happen and a hazard from an
incorrect test may not result in death
everybody thinks to worse and with all
things risk can never be totally
eliminated you must do a lot of times
you need to do evaluate if it's a risk
benefit or not and I'll give you an
example of something that I believe is a
risk benefit that's easy to understand
again ask these simple questions you're
going to first of all map out the
process you're going to look at what
could go wrong how likely it is to
happen how bad it could get and what
controls do I have to prevent or detect
this was provided by placing their EP 23
document and a fishbone document is not
a requirement on an IQ CP but a lot of
people in the world are very visual and
so a lot of people like looking at
things this way
the the spine here it of the fish is the
process itself and the bubbles that come
off here are where represent the five
main categories where the types of
failure that we're going to go into
later then along on the bones you're
going to see where listed things that
could go wrong another nice visual about
this is that you can actually draw
circles around the pre-analytical phase
post analytical phase on post analytical
phase and analytical phase and get a
good visual about your test you also can
take just your operating procedure with
its steps listed and write what could
possibly go wrong I'm just out to the
side you don't need to make this
complicated but i'm going to give you
several examples of how you can do this
again you've got to categorize on the
process steps you want to look at the
pre-analytical your analytical and your
post analytical and this is where we
have the blending of the five types of
error this is really important because
this is something that CMS is going to
be looking for they want categories such
as specimen test specimen or test system
environment reagents and testing
personnel for example for specimen um
you want to maybe go back and look at a
specimen rejection log for test system
review you need to look at your
maintenance logs review your test
results your proficiency testing and
quality control and the environment root
temperature humidity logs refrigerator
freezers temps reagents daily QC
internal QC lot to lot on comparisons
again testing personnel were used to
doing the training and the company
competency testing that's required for
non test non wave testing now if you
find that you're having a hard time to
decide which category that this fits it
under the step-by-step
written by CDC instant umass that's on
their website now it just says labs need
to ID the one components the most
appropriate for your laboratory so if
you're trying to sign if it's a test
system failure or reagent failure you
can ultimately just you just pick one if
you decide it's the reagent is the main
failure for your laboratory then that
would be what you would select on this
we're looking about looking at failure
and and we're going to do it until left
we're looking about how bad can it get
to the left and how how often is this
going to happen and I'd like to go
through a few practical examples on how
to use this table again this was given
with permission from clsi for usefulness
and first of all we're going to take a
look at negligible not something very
inconvenient or temporary versus
something that's frequent happening and
we're going to go to the next table it's
a matrix and we're going to try it and
and look at the table and see if it's an
acceptable risk or not so for frequent
and negligible know of getting not
acceptable the best example that I could
think about this is for example in a
nursery they decided to use new need um
he'll stick devices and a complaint came
down on the quality report that there
was an increased number of babies that
have bruised heels okay this is when
you're going to have to you know go back
through your quality control plan and do
a risk assessment so what are we not
controlling um that's causing this do we
need to have education for our
phlebotomist that are collecting the
samples or is it the heel stick device
itself that we made the change through
we'll go back and give you a different
example take a look at something that we
could result in patient death but it's
very probable that it should happen
and for me it was very surprising to see
that an improbable catastrophic would be
an acceptable risk the best example that
I could come up with for this one is
emergency release blood most doctors do
this because they're leaning out when
they come into the ed and they have no
choice they need to give that patient
blood but they're releasing that blood
with it not being completely screened
they have outweighed the risk involved
for giving that unscreened blood because
there's a better risk benefit that they
need blood in an emergency situation
another way to look at assessing risk is
to do it semi quantitatively and
basically what you do is you take the
frequency and the severity and detect
ability and you actually score these by
multiplying these green numbers together
I am NOT going to go into a lot of
detail for you miss the reason is that
we have a instruction guide that has
detailed instructions for this but I
wanted to make you well aware of this
remember detectability um helps reduce
the risk so I like that it's added if
it's if it's detectable or not and the
example we have is the values here or
art should be established for your own
laboratory your own scales so this is
just an example that doesn't mean it's a
range this value could be just as easily
less than 50 again if you're interested
in doing you're assessing your risk this
way you can find that information in our
instruction guide the next part of an
iqcp plan is the quality control and
keep in mind you but you may identify
processes through the risk assessment
that need additional controls /
you're doing a lateral flow test and you
didn't see in the insert that there was
a recommended humidity range before
running the test then that would be
something you would add to doing that
test you're going to link your existing
control existing and new pc process that
you discover from your risk assessment
to the failures and what you're going to
do the QC what it's going to do is they
can prevent and detect the failures one
advantage of iqcp is you might take a
look at a QC process you're using in
your laboratory and see that is not
detecting or preventing a failure iqcp
it gives you the freedom to discontinue
doing that quality control process if
it's not needed and on the third part is
the Quality Assurance that's to make
sure if you have a new failure during
your QC process that you need to take a
closer look at it if you need to add
more controls to you know to prevent or
detect the failure then you will do that
after you implement the new
quality-control you you'll continually
monitored to make sure that there are no
additional failures as a CIP inspector
i'm going to give you my viewpoint as a
volunteer i think that the checklist
questions and the standards from the
interpreting agencies and the guy step
guide are going to be the things that
you're going to need to keep in line
when you get ready for these inspections
I believe that they're going to look at
the process and not necessarily judge
you for your conclusions the reason that
I don't believe that the conclusions as
long as you use adequate data in him
sound reasoning I think that some labs
will have the exact same process but
they will not come up with the same
conclusion
great example would be running a test in
appeal el lab versus running in a core
laboratory first thing you need to do is
do an operating procedure for preparing
for your inspection keep in mind I
wouldn't start writing this first if you
guys would first take a look at doing a
risk assessment for a system in your lab
and maybe a second one I think after
you've done that it'll be very clear how
to write this operating procedure you
need to be careful um CMS has been lat
and the inspection teams are going to be
looking if you do this step especially
if you have a system and you're using it
in multiple places in the laboratory for
example if you're drawing a blood gas in
a neonatal he'll stick versus a
cardiovascular unit there's going to be
very different p analytical steps and
different personnel and even different
types of patients that's going to have
to be accounted for in your iqcp another
example is that even if you're doing
multiple floors for doing evaluation if
they're doing the same thing i would
highly suggest that you do an audit and
make sure that floor one is doing the
same thing as for three and a hospital
again this will be good documentation
that you clearly looked at using the
devices and different environments
you're going to review the quality
control plan the elements of it just
routine you're going to be looking at
your failures investigations also in
your proficiency testing if you have any
you're going to also be looking at your
corrective and preventable actions and
this will all be linked to your q's iqcp
the annual review of your point control
plan you've been doing that as always
and again you'll be linking these
changes as you see them in your iqcp the
next step is was your iqcp developed
with the right personnel this
step here to me is very important I
think we're really good in the walls of
the laboratory but then when we open up
we need to know if it's collected and
number another area input from those
users and also the people that are
involved or also the caregivers the
physician or the nurses doing the
treatment you may need to branch out in
your hospital to your risk assessment
people or your people or your expert
your nursing managers to give you input
especially in determining if something
is it has acceptable risk or not the
next one down here the they want enough
Claudine quality of data examples of
this could be looking back at your eq c
eq c data over the last two years i give
you the two year mark because this was
the suggestion that was put in the
step-by-step guide has been put out by
CMS is CDC you can be looking at your
maintenance records for the past few
years remember you've got to keep two
years of documentation anyhow for your
inspections and it's not as much
information as you think to look at
because remember you're just looking for
where there were problems the things
that are routine and you know they'll be
pages of routine information there but
the things that you note that where
there was a problem that's what you need
to closely look at the last thing
remember you're something to monitor the
quality of the test remember that you
know you always got to go back and if
there's a problem on the quality and you
just have to go back and do a new risk
assessment with the added failure and
take a closer look well the next part
the easy part because I've been involved
in this for at least over a year and a
Lear is very happy that we have formed
an iqcp paint that's cross-functional
it's involved actually salespeople
technical service people technical
consultants in the field marketing
scientific affairs and what I'm about to
show you are some of the things that
we are providing to our customers I'm
going to talk about our lear triage and
the reason i'm going to do that it fixes
i'm most familiar with it and but many
other vendors will have things that are
very similar that you can use first
important thing that I've really got to
highlight here is that any modification
to the document are the sole
responsibility of the facility this is
really important because once it gets in
your hands and as an Excel document it
gives you flexibility but it becomes
your document it's not a leer document
if you make make make changes on it one
of the things that I'm really proud of
is that we've made these documents easy
to get access to them and and be able
that you can use them in a way that's
practical for you I'm going to go over
each of the columns and how you might
complete this if this if you were doing
this test in your laboratory first
column here only see if I can get an
arrow here going because I think it will
help looking at this I the failure here
that's a failure or error and the
example we have on the first is operator
failure cause pretty common not
following manufacturer's instructions
again the five categories that CMS
requires we're going to tell you what
that is we consider that one to be at st
personnel error the potential effects of
the failure we are not going to complete
this for you that is because this is for
within your environment you need to
decide if this is a false positive false
negative the delayed results or invalid
results there may or any other
possibilities that you want to list in
there the next column is what the system
itself can do for mitigating risk we
have
in structures there on the screen are on
the screen of the instrument we also
have product labeling product labeling
includes package insert user manual we
even manufacturers are required to
relate our controls technical bulletins
all these things we provide this is
where the laboratory comes in and it
becomes part of your quality control
plan you have to sign in the laboratory
if that is enough risk mitigation
provided by a year and for this example
I would say no the things that i would
add if i worked in the laboratory would
be personnel testing would get more
training and i will have training in
cops d testing again we talked about
severity and frequency already and
you're going to have to determine that
for your laboratory and then the last
column on the far right there this is
where you would note your SOP number so
for a reference if you were had an
inspector there and you needed more
detail i'm going to give some more
examples so that you might get an idea
of how to use a spreadsheet once you
start working on your own the next
example that i'm going to give to you is
this one right here test device handling
let's say d the reagents were shipped at
an imp top improper temperature again
this failure is an environmental failure
alere shipping containers are designed
for your reagents to arrive at
appropriate control temperature we also
talked about it in our quality control
and warnings precautions but again on
this one i would add additional
information these are things you do
automatically for example you would when
you meet lee get a new shipment or like
you would do a lot to lot comparison so
you would add that information in here
next example is outdated test the device
used this could be a testing personnel
error but one thing is really nice our
expiration date is embedded in the
device barcode and it's red by the meter
so that's taken care of warnings and
precautions and expiration dating is
printed on every test device this is one
where the lab might say that none is
needed because this is being taken care
of with a barcode i this one I need to
give you a little background if you're
not familiar with the triage but the
reagents need to come to room
temperature before it's used a lot of
places do not want to wait for the
warmup time for the reagents after they
come after the refrigerator so with our
labeling we tell our customers that they
can lead them out at room temperature
but they cannot do it beyond the 14-day
room temperature storage again this
would be a reagent failure type and the
triage since it's a barcode it has no
idea that you if you've left that out
beyond the 14 days again there's more
information here for labeling and such
as even a technical bulletin that
describes these things and keep in mind
this would be one you would definitely
have to add more information you would
have to say that a testing personnel
have been educated on using a sharpie to
put a new out date because these reagent
devices have been left out at room
temperature remember this is just a
portion of your risk assessment this is
really on what I talked about where the
laboratory has to look closer at
everything that they need to take a
closer look at what procedures are in
place or what new ones they need to add
after identifying these risks and
remember quite control its sole purpose
is to detect and prevent these failures
a leer is here to support you I'm really
proud that we are
are providing vendor support for iqcp
you can call in to our technical
services you can scientific affairs is
involved are people in the fields of
support and technical consultants are
there to help you we even have an email
if you have a specific iqcp question be
sure an email I think Brenda did a push
through on what our webpage is one easy
way to get to it is you can google wwl
Eircom /i qcp and it does a pretty good
job getting there once you get to that
web page there's some really nice things
for you for helping you work on your
iqcp first our support documents are
there and like I said you're welcome to
retrieve them and use them in an excel
format we also have links to CMS with
documents about iqcp that we believe
will help you we also have a link to our
documents such as our package inserts
technical bulletins or anything is you
need as you start working on your iqcp
there's a another recorded webinar that
you're welcome to listen to and also PDF
a different webinar with a different
layer product for doing an iqcp so what
do you guys think have we given you some
ideas for making this easier what we're
going to do now is just go back over a
summary of everything we've talked about
today and and see if that stimulates any
questions at the end remember we talked
about you're going to have to do a
standard operating procedure the risk
assessment things package insert I think
I've already talked about vendor
information this would be your user
manuals technical bulletins maybe your
call history into technical services
that elior maybe it would be
it anything like a history on the
instrument lab information that would be
your competencies and your trainings in
your environment all these things you're
going to have to take a closer look at
clinical requirements again that's when
you bring that group of people in that
are going to be able to evaluate if it's
acceptable or not risk to be doing the
test that's way regulatory requirements
be very careful with this check with
local and state and even your crediting
agencies because I do believe they're
going to be different from place to
place again how do I prepare you collect
your data again the historic data you
can use and this is just the parts of
the risk assessment again you dinna Phi
the failures from your risk assessment
and where they happened calculate how
often and evaluate if there's an impact
or not you can map this is another
example instead of a fishbone diagram
you can do a mapping process again this
is up to you on how you like to look at
your processes in your laboratory you
categorize them in the steps of the five
different categories of types of
failures right now I'd like to kind of
talk about a way you can do this with
these excel spreadsheets you could
divide your Excel spreadsheet and do a
sort of just specimen or you could do an
analytical or pre-analytical and just
make an extra column and label your pre
and local steps and you can have those
sorted as a spreadsheet as you start
working on these spreadsheets you can
just maybe have a main iqcp plan and
it'd be the main tab but the second tab
would just be the exceptions for those
places where there are additional things
that have to protect from failure that
you'll be including in your iqcp so
again the flexibility i believe of using
excel is going to help a lot of people
in the laboratory
again you're going to ask what could go
wrong out there how likely it is to
happen how bad it could get and you can
do you have the right controls in place
or after junior risk assessment do you
need to add new controls again filling
out these tables it's not an exercise
and making sure the form is complete
it's it's about looking at quality
control in a whole different way in an
all inclusive way um in closing I know
your first iqcp if you've not done one
yet it really is a pretty painful
experience the first time you do it I
remember for example that the first one
we did for a risk assessment it took us
weeks to get through all the different
failures but one thing I found that once
you've done one it's a lot easy many
tests or systems have many commonalities
so as we've done a we're going to have
up to 20 different support documents
eventually added to our web page I've
gotten much better at looking at risk
assessment so practice helps remember as
we discussed in this presentation that
controls are much much more than just
doing your liquid controls and and
bringing all the things in that you
reaching Lee do in your laboratory or
just timing of that into your iqcp one
of the things about that is that the
step-by-step guide I really like they
have some nice Excel documents for
quality control to be listed separately
with an IQ CP and also quality
assessment so take a closer look at
those and see if those will help you for
organizing and like I said this is about
things you're already used to doing in
the laboratory and this is a shift from
doing just the regulatory compliance to
doing quality control for our test in
the laboratory and I want to thank
everyone for your participation today
and it's up to you to ultimately decide
if you want to do iqcp if you're more
comfortable with just doing two levels
of three levels of control daily that's
a fine that you can do that as
acceptable remember iqcp may not reduce
the number of controls you're currently
using but it will help you definitely
understand better which the things of
about quality control for the procedure
you're doing and with that I will take
questions Thank You Jane thank you for
that informative presentation we're so
happy to have you part of cardinal
health lab exchange i'm just going to
remind our audience how to ask questions
you can submit them green Q&A button
type your questions into the box it can
be found on the lower left of the
presentation window will try to get to
as many questions as we can and we do
have one question already from Cynthia a
cardinal health she asks if using eq c
today can you ought to do external QC
daily rather than iqcp i'm not exactly
sure of your question if you could
clarify our or do instead of doing EQC
that you would like to do daily eat
external controls instead of doing iqcp
that's the question as as I have it yes
that's correct if you choose that you
don't want to use eq c well you're not
gonna be able to use it I'll be honest
with you you would have to convert to
using external controls daily each day
of use of your test because that is the
new requirement if you do not do I qcp
okay our next question comes from dotty
a Capital Region medical center how does
the clsi streamlined QC plan for
microbiology sit in with iqcp I'll be
honest with you I'm not as familiar with
things in microbiology but it was just
recently I've noticed that ASM has given
some great support for microbiology and
doing iqcp s and i would i would go to
them if you haven't seen that yet I
think it's they're going to be a great
reference and guide everybody in
microbiology on how to use iqcp thanks
our next question from lashonda at saint
francis medical center how will this
work for susceptibility QC for micro i'm
going to give a repeat answer because i
actually saw some iqcp templates for
that again i would go to a sim
assistance for those
wait our next question comes from Chang
are their software programs for iqcp yes
there definitely are one of the ones out
there is extremely detailed and one is
more general and again you're going to
have to decide what is going to work
best for you I can't promote either one
but there are two out there and they are
available i actually have looked at both
of them and they are really nice thing
about them as i'm a person that likes
something that's computer-assisted you
know queueing you what you need to do
and one of the benefits of one of these
programs is that it asks you every
question really you don't have to think
about it the more details ask all the
questions the other one gives you more a
general high-level view great we have
one last question from Max a benefice
health system with iqcp be required on a
waved test system I definitely not if
you're using the test as wave iqcp is
not required great thanks that's what we
have time for I do want to thank our
sponsor a year for making today's
educational webcast possible please make
sure to head over to the community of
learning following this presentation and
you'll have an opportunity to engage in
live chat with jane smith and your peers
as well as have answers to more of your
brain questions in regards to iqcp
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October of
this year you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting me when that
broadcast will be available for replay
and we invite you to share that you know
any colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for coming
and we'll see you next time